imagine just living off of a single
battery to charge your phone for a month
and a half it's a rainy day here in
corridors so I've decided to tackle a
project that I've been wanting to do for
a very long time I want to build the
biggest portable power bank for my phone
using an old lipo battery that I'm gonna
rip apart resolder and repurpose for
this battery project I'm so excited
let's do this why do we have such a big
lipo battery well a few years ago we got
these really big drones to fly like red
cameras and stuff one drone required
three of these batteries to fly we ended
up getting rid of that drone but we kept
the batteries and so these guys sat on a
shelf for literally years this guy is
broken what one of these cells in fact
you can see it six cells in this bag
this cell right here is busted they
produce gases when they're not treated
very well they can expand in their own
container that's why you get old lipo
batteries and they're puffing right now
this battery is mostly fine however this
dead cell is preventing the rest of the
cells from functioning normally
we can't use this anymore right what are
you doing Sam you know get out of my way
around me no this is most efficient path
to the door this is an expensive battery
I don't want to just get rid of it so
I'm gonna try to repurpose it by
removing the dead cell and keeping the
five good cells this is where things get
a little dangerous if i pierce a little
too far into one of the battery packs it
could literally cause a chain reaction
and it can start burning we've done it
before check this out
I feel like this doesn't need to be said
but I'm gonna say it don't do this at
home the only reason why I'm doing this
is because I've spent a couple years
studying batteries and how they work I
feel comfortable enough that I can
handle this let's get to it
fire extinguisher is right there okay
I'm gonna make my first incision on this
lipo this outer layers - oh it's metal
ah it's a Lumina okay we're getting
close to this thing being well first I'm
just gonna remove the bad cell cut all
these wires in fact I'm gonna do that
right now yeah I don't need this balance
cable I'm using the wrong wire cutters
for this that was the dumbest thing it's
fine
the battery is fine it just shorted for
a moment I did short the battery that
and you got that on camera I am NOT
proud of that battery is fine
the battery is fine the wires are hot
I'm kind of burned my finger I know
better so hardcore that was I apparently
you don't know better apparently you're
right it's a light bro remember this
part where I said don't do this at home
I'm not kidding this is the dead cell
you can actually see it leaking here I'm
gonna have to wash my hands after this
that's toxic this is dangerous now this
surgery involves basically separating
each of the cells from each other and
this is where it gets a little hairy
I did not expect yeah I'm fine why did
it do that that was not good that was
scary
Oh oh it did short look at that you see
it made contact right here and more
specifically the scissors shorted that
out that's that's kind of scary I got to
be really careful not to let that happen
again my hands are shaking I'm gonna
walk away from this husband it's been
gone well a lot of great footage realize
my problem is that like I keep shorting
it out with the scissors gonna put
electrical tape over the contacts while
I cut through this stuff now I have five
perfectly good cells that I could also
just make five separate power banks with
but that's no fun I want to make the
biggest power bank so I'm gonna put all
these cells together in parallel as one
single giant battery imagine charging
eight phones from zero to a hundred
percent every day for a week or a single
phone for over a month I have taped them
together using just regular packing tape
each of these terminals gonna be you
solder to this wire and each of those
terminals are gonna be soldered to that
wire that should be easy
so the cool thing that allows you to do
DIY battery builds like this is that you
can buy these USB chargers really
cheaply online so I just bought like
several of them each little circuit
board has two USBs on them along with
the micro USB to charge so if I wire up
four of these circuit boards with two
USB ports on each I can charge up to
eight phones at the same time a power
bank of this size charging eight phones
that's kind of unheard of
okay why is that scissors I now have
four wires to use let's solder these
guys together I'm actually gonna wire
each of these little circuit boards
together in parallel so they're all
sourcing the same voltage and current
from the battery at the same time last
one last one then all the little circuit
board guys will be attached cut to
tomorrow so now I need to somehow a 3d
model a case that can hold both the
battery and each of these four USB
circuit boards so that they're all
secure and safe this battery is very
fragile it's very volatile and it's very
venerable literate alliterative
illiterate has a channel bull it's like
I think this next part is probably the
most challenging aspect for me because I
don't have much experience designing 3d
models this is a little outside my
experience of 3d modeling but I think I
can do it this is amazing and also the
case has been made look at that magic
right pretty basic it's just a PLA box
Nico's said just make it really big we
won't ever use it or anything I was like
what do you mean we'll never use it and
I think his fear is that it's gonna be
too janky so my mission suddenly became
we have to make something that we will
use we will use it
[Applause]
I miss so dearly I love rain makes me
wanna just drinks and try tug up in a
blanket and play some Dark Souls I'm
gonna put some apple cider and a pot and
heat it up it's like really bright but
also great I need to actually now solder
all my USB things to it okay yeah okay
okay I just accidentally short-circuited
the battery with the soldering iron
please tell me this is not one of those
videos where just like randomly sparks
everyone somewhere oh I don't want you
to blow your face up or burn the studio
down no I just trust me I don't want to
do either of those things
safety first you want to put your shirt
in front of your mouth once already
okay last one last one this turns on
we'll know it works ready it worked
charging but I think you need also put
like a warning do you put a warning at
these in these videos have you heard
about like those people who like you
know get thrown out of a plane and
somehow survive 10,000 foot drop
they're not authorities on skydiving
despite succeeding I'll be confident
enough to do it but I am definitely not
an authority on this but this is
actually the moment where you just
succeed so congratulations okay
technically this is the working battery
with eight USB ports it's time to put a
case on this and actually secure it into
its final form
hey and in other news look at that
that's really cool dude it looks like my
shirt and the spirit of reusing things
I'm actually gonna repurpose the insta
360 box and it should add some extra
protection and cushion to the battery so
that the chances of it getting punctured
is way lower so high quality cardboard
and so 360 good work so this is what I'm
talking about when I say liquid tape
it's basically electrical tape but it's
in liquid form so the idea is to get
every piece of metal completely covered
in this stuff even if it's a little hard
to like fit this in right now the foam
will compress over time something I
don't crack this thing in the mean time
and look at that so now I gotta figure
out a way to get these all fit in here
I thought about designing some screw
holes but screw that cyanoacrylate let's
go I'm using way too much glue you don't
need much superglue it's not like hot
glue or like epoxy or anything like that
where it actually has like physical
volume this stuff acts as a bonding
agent between two surfaces god my boys
are glued together they are they are my
god my finger actually is straight-up
glued I can't I'm like trying to
separate Wow okay so there I was after
all this effort making a battery that
can power eight phones hey does anyone
need some electricity and their phone is
[Music]
gentle okay
ah you know that hey Ren wanted room for
one more
sweet we are gonna really charge from
six bones our new whoo
and we can go for a run turning out his
porn let's rock let's run run run now
let's all get on one wheel